so a woman says she's afraid to stay in
her own house after two men armed with a
gun broke in this happened near Rainbow
and Ulta Monday evening she was asleep
at the time says they stole thousands of
dollars from her Joshua paguerra shows
us the video and offers tips on how you
can protect yourself
this ring door video camera captured two
people breaking inside this home the
home's alarms didn't go off and experts
believe the suspects may have had a
device that disabled the Wi-Fi turning
off their security system might have
lost
everything I had
but I'm still here lovely Clinton is
feeling anxious living inside a home she
bought three months ago her security
camera captured two burglars holding a
gun and using a pig to get in I was up
all last night
just sitting in the middle of the bed
with my phone and the gun my son gave me
I can't be hearing stuff police showed
up the night of the break-in now she has
taken action to feel safe she just had
security technicians installing more
cameras and plans to install bars on her
Windows
Clinton says the thieves stole 47 000
she had stash in envelopes the money was
going towards paying contractors
currently working on her house she owns
a food truck and does catering crime
experts recommend getting to know your
neighbor so you can alert each other it
was all I had
and maybe they needed it more than me
Security Experts recommend getting a
hardwired security camera rather than
one connected to Wi-Fi reporting in West
Las Vegas Joshua progero 8 News Now